unlv school of dental medicine just
received a massive donation to help with
their school's
women's dental clinics many of which had
to close down due to the pandemic
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
has the latest
sasha a non-profit organization called
dentaquest donated 25
thousand dollars to the dental school
providing care for women children
veterans
and homeless individuals the dentaquest
funds will directly support patient care
provided by faculty students and staff
at the school's on-site community
outreach clinics unlv's dental school
works directly with the shade tree
a local shelter in las vegas to provide
these services to those in need
if the person needs more than just a
standard cleaning the person will be
directed to their main clinic free of
charge
this allows us to provide direct care
they come in they're identified
we appoint them our students provide
this care
so they don't have to worry about these
costs our faculty give their saturdays
and they're here
helping monitor and help teach
dentaquest has helped the school before
but this is the biggest amount they have
ever donated which allows the school to
see more patients and open up more
clinics
and the women's clinic started 10 years
ago and since then they have been able
to provide care for over a thousand
people
so the hope with this money is that they
can increase that substantially
reporting in las vegas madison kimbrough
8 news now